>> IT'S A LATE NIGHT.
THEY WILL GET ON A FLIGHT
TOMORROW, AND THEN THEY HAVE TO
IS THERE GAME ONE SUNDAY
AFTERNOON.
>> MULTIPLE STARS RIGHT NOUVEL
WITH THE CLIPPERS.
THE HUGS ARE STILL COMING OTHER.
MALL GEORGE, 50 YEARS THE
FRANCHISE HAPPENS BEEN WAITING
TO GET TO A CONFERENCE FINAL.
WHAT DOES IT PANEL FINAL HI
FOLLOW LIKE
>> IT NUMBER FEELS GREAT.
WHEN KAWHI WENT DOWN WE KNEW
EVERYBODY HAD TO STEP UP.
WE SEND OUR PRAYERS OUT TO HIM
AND HOPE HE GETS HEALTHY.
HE CARRIED IS UP.
>> YOU KNOW FROM NOW ON WE'LL
CALL YOU THE TAINS MAN GAME.
>> YEAH.
I EVERY JEPT TELLING ME TO SHOOT
THE BALL, SHOOT THE BALL AND
IT'S WHAT I DID.
>> YES, YES.
WE WORKS ON MISS GAME COMB:
REMINDS ME A LOT OF MYSELF.
HE PUTS THE WORK IN.
WE TELL HIM YOU COME OUT HERE
AND WORK SO HARD FOR WHAT, COME
OUT AND SHOW IT.
HE CAME IN AND PLAYED WITH
CONFIDENCE.
YOU SAW WHAT -- YOU GOT TO KNOW.
>> I REALLY DON'T KNOW.
>> YOU GOT TO KNOW WHAT YOU
HAVE.
>> I LOOKED UP AND I HAD 34 AND
THAT'S THE LAST THING I SEEN.
>> THAT WAS A WHILE AGO.
>> THAT'S AMAZING.
YOU MENTIONED KAWHI BEING OUT.
OF COURSE, WE DON'T KNOW IF HE'S
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BE BACK WITH
YOU IN THE INCOMES SEASON.
WHAT CAN YOU GUYS DO TO CONTINUE
ON WITHOUT HIM BECAUSE YOU HAVE
SAID, PAUL, THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
THE BEST PLAYER ON THIS SEEM
SGHL I THOUGHT THE FIRST HALF WE
GOT AWAY FROM IT AND I TRITED SO
I JUST TRUSTED MY TOMAS AND MY
PASSING ABILITIES.
GOT TO THE PAINT AND TRIED TO
MAKE PLAYS AND MY TEAMMATES
REALLY DID ALL THE WORK.
I JUST HAD TO MAKE IT HAPPEN,
AND THEY DID EVERYTHING ELSE, SO
THIS WIN IS REALLY CREDIT TO ALL
MY TEAMMATES MAN.
>> IT'S A VERY QUICK TURNAROUND.
WE WILL SEE YOU GUYS JUST ON
SUNDAY IN PHOENIX.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU.